[Music]
welcome back to game on vegas the aces
open their 2021 home slight and
dominating fashion on friday night with
a 28-point win over the la sparks
it was their first time playing here at
home in 605 days
they were looking to double down and
carry that win over today's matchup
with connecticut the reigning league mvp
asia wilson showing off the range early
knocks down the deep two then it's some
vegas defense oh my gosh
welcome to the rakana williams block
party let's take another look at it
that is what you call
denied check that out now we head to the
second quarter aces trailing by double
digits but derrick heavy sparking
the rally more vegas defense and then
more blocks liz cambage six eight yeah
she makes this look so easy with the
rejection immediately
then we head on to aces in transition
destiny slocum the rookie finds williams
count all three of those it's a one
point game
and then of course more defense and
that's going to lead to
offense sloka pushing it ahead to
chelsea gray here
she gets the rebound and then gray you
can count
all three of these vegas in front by two
into the third and it's cam beige light
work in the paint
ace is up by six determined
and then check out this weekend sequence
hamby to wilson
see the beautiful feed to cam beige late
fourth quarter action mayor elise is
trailing by double digits but
still fighting despite the no quit the
aces fall 72-65 to connecticut
afterwards the team spoke about the lack
of energy
well we knew we were going to be a bumpy
road early in the season but tonight is
a game we probably could have won
uh it was unfortunate that you know we
had a lot of players that didn't really
get on track
to give credit to their defense uh you
know it's who they are they play solid
physical basketball
uh but our energy level was was not not
there at all today i think that was
the most disappointing thing about our
team uh so once we play with energy and
push the ball we're really good in
transition
we got some buckets so it fueled our
energy got some stops
picked up the loose balls because we had
that extra extra little
step in our we or whatever you want to
call it
and that's what got us back in the game
and we just couldn't find that in the
starting unit
i mean they're a good basketball team
they've been together for a long time
they know exactly what they need to do i
don't think
individually they did anything it was
just a collective group that came out
with a defensive mindset they would
hit first and we just got to understand
that that's what team's going to try to
do with us
but we can't really shake us we got to
continue to do us and what we know how
to do
and really focus on us i mean i can't
tell you much about that because i was
so focused on myself
was so focused on my teammates uh but at
the end of the day you know they made a
good defensive effort and when you play
defense well it translates over to the
offensive side
you never really want to say that you're
peaking in the beginning right
you want to get wins and learn from it
obviously we would
learn from this game um whether we won
or lost
um it just stings a lot more we know we
didn't play well we didn't
play to our strengths at all um
but i think we're gonna be fine just uh
keep communicating keep her hesitate
all right the ace is now sitting at two
and two they head to phoenix on
wednesday to take
on the mercury ron